er ist das jetzt sinnvoll nach urlaub zu
buchen ja die lage ist irgendwie sehr
verwirrend aber natürlich sollte man
sich nicht unbedingt davon abbringen
lassen jetzt urlaub zu buchen
ja notfalls in deutschland aber
tatsächlich die unsicherheit ist
wirklich sehr groß wohin kann ich noch
verreisen
wir reden immer über mallorca natürlich
kann man danach wunderbar hin reisen
aber man muss wissen man muss halt auf
der straße außer am strand mit einer
maske rumlaufen dass bei 30 grad auch
nicht so angenehm also tatsächlich
urlaub sollte man sich nicht vermiesen
lassen aber immer genau schauen was
gerade die lage ist ansonsten in
deutschland dankeschön frank für im
moment wir wollen einmal kurz schauen in
einer umfrage wir haben uns nämlich am
stuttgarter flughafen umgehört und
nachgefragt warum viele deutsche
trotzdem noch nach barcelona fliegen
obwohl es ja jetzt eine reisewarnung
gibt
wir fliegen heute nach barcelona weil
wir noch richtung barcelona circa
eineinhalb stunden fahrzeugen im auto
uns aufhalten werden und ich direkt in
barcelona wir haben nur die gebundenheit
an den flughafen und mehr auch nicht
also wir holen in barcelona und wir
möchten ja nach anbieter also wir waren
jetzt drei wochen hier im urlaub die
eltern besuchen verwandte besuchen und
jetzt gehen wir wieder zurück nach hause
tatsächlich habe ich selber festgestellt
wenn sie jetzt nicht die familie zu
besuchen wäre wäre ich nicht geflogen
weil es einfach darum geht das ganze
flair ist nicht vorhanden ist es uns
klar dass das von risikogebiete zum
riesige gebiet erklärt wurde uns haben
wir viele freunde jetzt irgendwelche
links geschickt und so aber so die leute
die wir dort kennen und die connections
die wir dort haben die sagen ist es
wirklich ganz anders wie es in den
medien dargestellt wird und es ist auch
wirklich nur in barcelona eben diese
hohe gefahr fürs umlaufbahn und bei mir
im studio ist immer noch frank ochse der
bild spar volks-ja frank was passiert
mit meiner gebuchten reise wenn ich
schon fix etwas gebucht habe jetzt kommt
darauf an was sie gebucht haben ist es
eine pauschalreise dann wird der
veranstaltung diese reise absagen wenn
jetzt mein zielgebiet jetzt plötzlich
risikogebiet ist wenn ich separat
gebucht habe also flüge hotel getrennt
dann sind sie immer auf die kulanz der
anbieter angewiesen weil zum beispiel
die flüge ja trotzdem stattfinden
da muss man schauen wie sieht es damit
kulanzregelungen aus oder bei hotels
einfach fragen ob man umbuchen kann
dann das geld sofort wieder bekommt
hängt dann wieder vom recht im
urlaubsland ab und das ist manchmal
nicht so einfach zu verstehen wie wir
unser recht kann man sich dann irgendwie
absichern oder gibt es mittlerweile
sogar schon eine koronare
reiserücktrittsversicherung jetzt
wirklich auch ein mythos dass eine
reiserücktrittsversicherung auch bei
corona einspringt das ist nicht der fall
also habe ich angst vor corona und bin
jetzt nicht plötzlich erkrankt das ist
halt die definition bei einer
reiserücktrittsversicherung das heißt
also auch eine krankheit die vielleicht
erwarte ist kein grund diese
reiserücktritts versicherung in anspruch
zu nehmen das heißt ich muss plötzlich
erkrankt seien an kroner ist sicherlich
auch ein grund aber man kann sich da
grundsätzlich nicht dafür absichern und
sagen ich habe eine
reiserücktrittsversicherung also kann
mir nichts passieren